[Music]
on this Monday night demanding answers
into Rodney Levi's death these are there
to protect and serve not assault and
kill to indigenous people who have died
at the hands of police in New Brunswick
plus one city's new plan to fight
systemic racism disturbing new video of
George Floyd's arrest what he's bought
is right Oh more evidence of how police
ignored horrified bystanders
plus amplified calls for accountability
from the family of Rashard Brooks
I can ever give a resume and more money
on the way a Canada emergency response
benefit is getting extended
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin in New Brunswick where
officials are rethinking a plan to give
police more powers after two indigenous
people were shot and killed by police in
eight days the province had been
considering a controversial new plan to
give police new powers to enforce
pandemic restrictions it would have
allowed officers to stop people and ask
for documentation without reason premier
Blaine Higgs backed off that idea today
he says in light of the police shootings
it's more important to focus on ending
systemic racism I think Friday night
changed things for a lot of people and
including myself I think it's important
now to focus on the healing process and
certainly what needs to take place in
order to ensure that that we can
identify some of the chronic concerns
maybe that have lasted for generations
it was on Friday night that a 48 year
old nigma man named Rodney Levi was shot
and killed by an RCMP officer at a home
near mirror machine eight days before
that also in New Brunswick a 26 year old
indigenous woman was shot and killed at
her home after police were called to do
a wellness check as Ross Lauren reports
in both cases family and friends are
demanding answers and justice a New
Brunswick's met upon Agua first nation
Rodney Levi was known as troubled but
community leaders say he did not deserve
to die I think a lot of our people are
getting hurt and are killed at the hands
of police and police are there to
protect insert not assault and kill go
along well with the chief there got
along with the pastor as well and that's
all we know
he had some mental health issues there
was a mental health crisis and now he's
dead the RCMP says members responded to
a report of an unwanted person in a home
but a clergyman Reverend Brodie McLeod
says Rodney Levi was a welcomed guest at
our home
he adds Levi shared a meal with the
Reverend at his family on Friday evening
nigma Chief Bill Ward suggests after the
barbecue Levi had a mental breakdown an
RCMP statement says a man armed with
knives charged at officers that a stun
gun was used unsuccessfully then an
officer fired a shot that proved to be
fatal
the weekend tragedy coincided with
healing walks paying tribute to Chantal
Moore on June 4th Moore was shot and
killed by city police in Edmundston New
Brunswick
after officers came to her apartment to
conduct a wellness check Morris family
wants a public inquiry instead of the
more limited coroner's inquest that's
been ordered new brunswick has no
special investigation unit for police
shootings it's called in a unit from
Quebec to examine both deaths a move
this analyst says further undermines the
prospect of a thorough review somebody
who's coming to you know from outside
the jurisdiction doesn't know the
geography doesn't know the people or the
context in which the killing took place
Perry Belgard Assembly First Nations
National chief says such reviews need to
include more civilians including
indigenous leaders the most important
thing now is to focus our energies and
our efforts on fixing the system what
can we do now to prevent you know these
hurtful and the drastic takedowns
excessive use of force in the future the
RCMP says investigators from Quebec have
arrived in New Brunswick to begin their
investigation
Ross Lord Global News a new report two
years in the making has found the city
of Montreal has turned a blind eye to
racism mayor Valeri plant is promising
to act on what she calls systemic racism
affecting racialized communities and
indigenous people the Premier of Quebec
though says he does not believe systemic
racism exists in his province Eric
Sorenson explains like any big city
Montreal has confronted racially charged
shooting deaths that have sparked
violence and other questionable police
conduct but the problem of racism goes
beyond the police consultations last
year found discrimination towards
racialized and indigenous people in
everything from employment to housing a
new report says the city has turned a
blind eye to the relationship of power
between majority and minority groups it
was said very clearly the blind eyes I
mean of course it hurts because that's
not what I want as mayor in this highly
diverse City
Montreal's mayor says there is systemic
racism and it will be addressed
announcing the creation of a
commissioner to lead the fight new
hiring targets for underrepresented
groups mandatory training to counter
discrimination and at the street level
police body cameras for more
accountability I want you to know that
Montreal is a city where every month
trailers is entitled to have their
dignity respected anti racism advocates
are pleased with the report but want to
see more from City Hall and the police
we need concrete measures to ensure that
the SPM does not partake in any form of
racial profiling and police brutality
Quebec Premier has insisted there is no
systemic racism in that province but now
Francois Lugo is forming a new committee
to address racism he doesn't want to
quarrel over the word systemic why do we
have to fight for months about one word
instead of fighting together against
racism the goal was backed up by Cabinet
ministers who've experienced racism
firsthand I have been victim of racism
join me during my career ask me which
type of racism for me it's racism period
Prime Minister Trudeau is promising
action at the national level right away
indigenous peoples black Canadians and
racialized Canadians are far more likely
to suffer a violence at the hands of the
authorities and police and so the Prime
Minister suggests within days Ottawa
will share plans to address what he
calls the systemic racism that has
existed for too long in this country
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
another video has surfaced of those
terrible minutes George Floyd was pinned
to the ground by police in Minneapolis
the lawyer representing Floyd's family
has released it a warning it is
disturbing to watch it was taken by a
bystander you can hear people pleading
with the police to get off Floyd and to
check his pulse to see if he's still
alive
just go take your clothes get back in
check the many moves yet bro
it went on for minutes the police
ignored their police fired police
officer Derrick Chauvin knelt on the 46
year old's neck for nearly nine minutes
while Floyd said I can't breathe
joven has been charged with
second-degree murder the other officers
seen in this video to tau is one of
three former officers charged with
aiding and abetting murder the whole
world now knows what happened to George
Floyd and he was not the first black man
to die in police custody despite all the
black lives matter protests and all the
calls for an end to racial profiling and
police brutality another black man was
killed in Atlanta by the police and
today his death was ruled a homicide
Jennifer Johnson reports and a warning
this story also contains video that's
disturbing a peaceful protest outside
Georgia State Capitol demanding reform
and justice after the death of Rashard
Brooks the county coroner has ruled
Brooks death a homicide video shows
officer Garrett Rolf allegedly firing
his weapon at Brooks after Brooks
pointed a Taser at the officer Brooks
family is devastated I can never get my
husband back I can never get my best
friend I can never tell my daughter so
he's coming to take his scared what
swimming lessons look at your children
when you see him laughs that innocence
that joy that pureness of soul you had a
glimpse of what we lost the deadly
incident Friday night began after Brooks
failed a sobriety test at a Wendy's
restaurant and offered to walk to his
sister's house will you take a familiar
breath test for me since yes or no
I don't want to refuse anything but what
started out as a cordial conversation
turned deadly officer Rolf has been
fired the second officer at the scene
Devon Brosnan placed on administrative
duty the district attorney says criminal
charges may be filed the Georgia Bureau
of Investigation is conducting a probe
it's xlviii investigation of a police
involved shooting this year the first
call was because a man was sleep where
is the empathy and just letting him walk
home
that's what policing is supposed to be
no matter what color you are
the Brooks case causing more fury after
George Floyd's death in Minneapolis
sparked weeks of protests from cities
across America and in Congress there are
calls for new laws to put an end to
police brutality the problem is white
supremacy the dehumanization of
communities that we live in this is
about accountability its systemic change
protestors promise to keep taking to the
streets until changes are made Jennifer
Johnson Global News Washington
LGBTQ two people in the United States
are celebrating a landmark Supreme Court
ruling that will protect them from
discrimination at work in a 63 decision
the justices ruled the 1964 Civil Rights
Act which bars workplace discrimination
based on race and sex also covers sexual
orientation and gender identity
twenty-eight states didn't have those
protections before today the victory is
bittersweet though one of the plaintiffs
in this case
Amy Stevens their transgender woman from
Michigan died last month before knowing
the outcome of her historic court battle
it is considered the biggest victory for
LGBTQ to Americans since the Supreme
Court ruling legalized same-sex marriage
five years ago this month a Canadian
sentenced in Russia for spying this is
simply a dog and pony show for the media
coming up Paul Wieland's punishment and
the pleas for political intervention
a Moscow Court has convicted a Canadian
man on spying charges Paul Whelan now
faces up to 16 years in a
maximum-security Russian prison he also
holds citizenship in the US where he
served as a Marine and he has British
and Irish citizenship the US has
denounced the trial as an egregious
violation of Human Rights and his
crystal commencing reports Whelan and
his family fear he's become a political
pawn this is simply a dog and pony show
for the media Paul Whelan says he is the
victim of a setup
Russian authorities say he is an
American spy guilty of espionage in
Russian Whelan was handed a 16 year
sentence in a maximum security prison
his lawyer says no evidence was ever
presented proving the allegations in
2018 the former US Marine was in Moscow
for a friend's wedding
he was arrested Russian authorities say
a flash drive found in his jacket
contained classified information I've
described these proceedings as a mockery
of justice and today just confirmed it
an American citizen has been sentenced
to a term of 16 years for a crime for
which we have not seen evidence Whelan
was born in Ottawa but had been living
in the u.s. his family in both countries
has been so silent for 18 months about
Paul's case he's had health issues and
recently underwent an emergency
operation to repair a hernia the 50 year
old addressed his health in a
handwritten message he held up from the
prisoners box meatball surgery can be
slang for shoddy medical work the note
also called for political help and ended
with an odd birthday greeting to Flora
his family says it is a good sign that
he's able to think about his golden
retriever we hope that the Russian
Federation and the United States
government will now speak to each other
about possibly resolving it with the
resolution being his freedom that may
take the form of a prisoner swamp but
his twin brother says for now that is
just a hope krystal the Manson Global
News London
Maria Reza a high-profile journalist in
the Philippines known for her fearless
reporting has been found guilty of libel
a decision seen as a test case of media
freedom Reza founded a news website
called rap ler that's done investigative
stories on president rodrigo duterte
the case relates to an eight-year-old
story which cites an intelligence report
linking a wealthy businessman to a
murder drug dealing and human
trafficking case residens the libel
charges her supporters say they were
trumped up aimed at intimidating those
who challenged Duterte and his brutal
war on drugs the rules are very clear
this kind of grey area
if you go too far you know you'll get
slammed let's not play the game are we a
democracy or not let us do our jobs
Reza was one of the journalists dubbed
the Guardians by Time magazine in 2018
she faces up to six years in jail her
colleague ronaldo santos junior was also
found guilty both deny any wrongdoing in
her free on bail pending an appeal ahead
the money keeps flowing mccanna de
emergency benefit will get an extension
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau says the
Canada emergency response benefit or
serve will be extended beyond the
original term the benefit pays $2,000 a
month for up to four months that means
those who applied in April will run out
in early July and they still might not
have a job to go to almost nine million
Canadians have applied for the serve and
more than 43 billion dollars has been
paid out the Prime Minister says details
of the extension are coming people have
questions about what's going to happen
as they end their serve benefits in the
coming month and are worried that
they're not going to be able to find
another job I will be making an
announcement in the coming days on on
that extension and on that issue last
week the Parliamentary Budget Officer
said extending the program through
January of 2021
could cost taxpayers an additional fifty
seven billion dollars Quebec is easing
more of its physical distancing
restrictions as the daily number of new
covent cases there decreases Quebec will
allow indoor gatherings of up to 50
people starting next Monday seated
venues like movie theaters will be able
to reopen provided people can sit at
least 1.5 meters apart gatherings at
home are limited to just 10 people
meeting under the same roof and they
must be from a maximum of three
households rules are also relaxing for
children under the age of 16 allowing
them to be just one meter apart at
places like schools and summer camps
Quebec reported 102 confirmed new cases
today and 20 deaths seven more regions
will enter Stage two of Ontario's
reopening plan this Friday but three
major regions near Quebec and the US
border have been left off that list as
new clusters of kovin 19 emerge Ontario
Premier Doug Ford said today all regions
other than Toronto peel and Windsor will
enter Stage two on Friday
meaning more restaurants and bars can
reopen those three regions need to get
numbers down before they follow suit the
majority of Ontario's health units
reported five or fewer new cases today
in Windsor alone though to care homes
are dealing with new outbreaks and fifth
d agricultural workers were reported
positive over the weekend for the
region's still remaining in stage one
Toronto
peel and Windsor Essex we ask you please
be patient because we can't let our
guard down there's more news tonight
about the drug hydroxychloroquine US
regulators have revoked authorization
for its emergency use on kovat 19
patients the US Food and Drug
Administration says available scientific
evidence shows hydroxychloroquine and a
related drug are unlikely to be
effective against the new coronavirus
and carry too many risks without any
apparent benefit for people with Kovan
19 the drug is approved for treatment of
malaria and autoimmune conditions like
lupus american president donald trump
has promoted hydroxychloroquine as a
miracle cure for Kovach 19 and claimed
to have taken it himself to prevent
getting a virus china's densely
populated capital beijing has put in
place strict lockdown measures after a
resurgence of kovat 19 a cluster of new
cases has led to fears of community
spread
they've been traced to a big bustling
Beijing market the biggest wholesale
food market in Asia that has triggered a
lockdown people living near the market
aren't allowed to leave and nobody is
allowed in tens of thousands of people
are being tested after two months of no
new cases 79 have now been detected in
this outbreak and Chinese officials fear
communities spread could lead to other
outbreaks up next a closer look at
classrooms as the pandemic persists
no student or teacher will forget how
topsy-turvy the last few months of
education have been and as we look to
the fall schools students and parents
are trying to figure out what the new
reality of Education in a pandemic will
look like our Mike Armstrong visited
Howick elementary it's about an hour
southwest of Montreal where classes are
back in session and the way things are
organized could be a lesson for us all
there is a new activity at Howick
Elementary School thanks to kovat 19 two
weeks ago cycling was added to gym class
kids bring their own bikes from home
it's something that makes physical
distancing easy and cuts down on
possible transmission the bikes it's
just to have another activity that have
them able to use some equipment because
it's hard to land out equipment unless
we're washing it every single time
no it's your recess keeping things clean
is a challenge even soccer balls are
being sanitized several times a day now
journalists aren't allowed inside the
school when kids are in class so it's a
little strange but principal melodie
primo took one of our small cameras
inside to give us an idea of how things
look I'll even get the door for you no
thank you
it is sparse the government rule is that
kids have to be two metres apart but the
staff found that wasn't enough the
students needed extra space so they can
get up and stretch from time to time
another measure to help with physical
distancing they now have a door for
coming into the building and another one
for going out there are also markings on
the florist to remind kids to stay to
the right in hallways principal primo
says it's worked fairly well I'd say 95
percent of the time yes but we're human
and sometimes we cross paths and we back
up no attendance is still optional and
most kids haven't come back they're only
at about 25 percent but that's given
Quebec schools the chance to do a sort
of dry run for the fall one the rest of
the country is watching so it is a
challenge well butters runs the new
frontier school board
for the last couple of weeks I've had
colleagues from around Canada reach out
to me to ask my advice or my experience
or is this for real or how are you guys
doing this or what should we look out
for there are major changes and debates
going on in education right now and
butter says it's not going to look the
same in 10 years but he does think it
will be better Mike Armstrong Global
News Howard Quebec and that is global
national for this Monday I'm Donna
Friesen tonight's your Canada is the
hamlet of Harry Hill in Alberta named
for the bison hair left behind by herds
shedding their winter coats thanks for
watching and I hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye bye
[Music]
you